the independent analysts say other tax
cuts in the past have been bigger than
this one but the bill which is hundreds
of pages long will affect the daily
lives of Americans at every income level
big issues include whether cutting
corporate taxes will give workers bigger
paychecks how the new law will affect
home buyers and sellers and the tax
deductions that are going away Lea
Gallagher is senior editor at large for
a fortune magazine is here with some of
the answers to some of those questions
good morning good morning leave much to
discuss listen the Democrats are jeering
the Republicans are cheering you know
the president called it what do you say
an incredible gift for Christmas right
and a big beautiful tax a big beautiful
Democrats called it a disgrace so who's
telling the truth here who are the
winners and losers well I think that
just tells you how polarizing this whole
debate has been and how this this
legislative you know win for the
president has been a big game of
political football I mean the last time
we passed a major tax reform it was not
you know not a single Democrat we know
voted for this one and that was not the
case last time so it's been an
incredible political battle so let's
break it down go through it so some
companies have already made commitments
essentially to give back Boeing
announcing 300 million dollars for
things like gift matching workplace
development AT&T Comcast talking about
bonuses how does that work out that
reinvestment in employee well it's
interesting so I think this really
speaks to you know there's been an
enormous amount of public disaffection
with this bill there's an incredible
feeling that it favors businesses and it
favors the wealthy which it does but you
know AT&T is an interesting example it's
in it's locked in a fight with the
administration over whether it can will
be allowed to acquire Time Warner so
this this look this is a big deal in
AT&T also said it's going to invest a
billion dollars here in the u.s. next
year in addition to the bonuses in
fairness to Randall Stephenson the CEO
of AT&T I was with him before they tried
to block that deal and he was already
talking about reinvesting in workers
before that exactly but you know you can
almost see that these companies were
writing the tweets for the president
because this is sort of a line straight
to his heart they are showing right away
that look this is for you know the tax
cut is passed on one day day - it's
raining with money there's no obligation
to do that though they're not no no
there
and what's the like what's the
likelihood then that once you get past
this initial PRF this will be a pattern
of a well that there's a lot of
skepticism around that but I will say
also those companies it's not just bonus
and some of them are raising the minimum
wage so that that is a significant yeah
and so but the big criticism is that
companies will use this money to
reinvest by buying back their stock and
by paying dividends and all we're sort
of in an era of financial engineering
and capital finds the way that it's you
know flows to the way it's most used so
the Speaker of the House Paul Ryan
talked about inversions that companies
are taking their money overseas and
keeping it there what in this tax bill
means that they're gonna bring that
money back home so there is a what's
called a deeded repatriation which is a
way of saying the tax bill offers a very
low rate 15.5% for cash for companies to
bring that money back to the US now it's
also switching to a territorial system
of global taxation which you know means
it's it's not likely that that's gonna
be as huge as I think you know everyone
is saying it will be we did a tax
holiday in 2004 and it actually didn't
result in so much reinvestment in the
American economy because people think
why don't we keep it over there here's a
question what stands out to you that's
in the bill that we might not have heard
about we know it's hundred pages long
there's so much in there I mean there's
a lot of little things that actually
people don't know about it mortgage
interest deduction a mortgage engine
that is a huge one and in fact that's
the one thing that I think is most
surprising because the mortgage interest
deduction is something that most
economists agree is not a good tax
policy it's regressive it favors the
wealthy it pushes us into single-family
homes but that's we watched yeah and so
it's still there but it's there but it's
been reduced and how does this affect it
look that a home is is most people's
it's the biggest investment they make in
their life how does this affect that
much it really affects the affordability
mass you know when you look at what your
house is gonna cost you every month if
you're buying you factor in that
interest deductions it's a big part of
it as is deducting property taxes and in
some states that's gonna change in how
expensive states there's a cap on
property deduction stuff so this is
gonna affect the real estate market so
in one Teachers Union estimates that
that cap on those state and local taxes
could lead to an estimated two hundred
and fifty billion dollars in cuts to
public education yes why would that fund
it'd be harder for schools to raise
taxes because of this change in in
people are gonna really be crimped and
what they can deduct in their local
taxes so that's gonna hurt everybody but
something about alimony
the interesting thing so divorce alimony
payments are deductible now they're no
longer going to be but that was gonna
take place next year which might have
meant we would have seen a rush of
divorces in the next seven days and now
they pushed it off for another year so
don't worry about that okay but other
things you can no longer deduct your tax
preparation expenses I mean that seems
like a such a given to me I don't know
you can't deduct taxes if you the cost
of your move if you move for work you're
no longer able to deduct those costs I
just moved I mean those are not going to
be that's expensive I'm yeah thanks
deduction so there are other things like
that that I think people don't know
about and the IRS by the way is going to
be so overwhelmed dealing with all this
this was pushed through incredibly fast
so your accountant if you have one my
city you're getting 50 calls a day about
this so it's a big deal we going thank
you for taking us through all those
thank you for asking and get your
employer to pay for your move I don't
know about that